there is no room for any deviation from
our Central objective of the year which
is to halve inflation so that we deal
with the anger for example of public
sector workers who are seeing their pay
eroded we deal with the pressure that
pensioners are seeing when they're doing
their weekly shop the pressure on
businesses where it's sometimes about
their viability this has to be our
Central Mission and that's why the prime
minister's nailed his colors to the Mast
and said we are going to halve inflation
over the next year
and standing by for is in the city this
morning and King live at uh 10 o'clock
this morning of course thoughts from
those inflation figures here good
morning
hello okay well I mean I guess you could
say it's encouraging that inflation has
fallen from a for a consecutive second
month third remember it was at 11.1 in
October but really that's as far as the
good news goes don't forget inflation is
still more than five times the bank of
England's Target rate of two percent uh
so there's the trajectories you can see
there so it's just coming off the peak
there I think the real uh disappointing
element in the numbers today is that
core inflation which is the element that
strips out to volatile elements such as
food drink alcohol and tobacco well that
was unchanged at 6.3 percent which was
marginally higher than anticipated most
of the decline that we've seen today was
actually because motor fuel uh prices
fell in the inflation basket uh the
sixth consecutive month actually that
petrol and diesel prices have fallen
what's really doing the damage to that
Top Line inflation number is food
inflation which uh during the month of
December was at a 45-year high of some
16.9 percent that is largely due to
components such as milk eggs and cheese
which have been driven Higher by animal
feed prices for example fertilizer
prices and of course elevated fuel
prices which continues to have a
knock-on effect in the food supply chain
so there's not a lot to write home about
here if one's honest there was another
exacerbating Factor on food prices I
should say sugar and confectionery
prices were somewhat higher than usual
and that's because of export controls in
India where they're also failures in
some Harvest it just shows you what a
globalized world in which we live so can
one say that inflation has Peaks
probably you can but that's as good as
it gets it's worth pointing out that
inflation remains higher than it's than
it is other countries uh United States
their December inflation number was six
and a half percent in Germany it's still
relatively elevated but down to 9.6
there so there is a sort of stickier
element to inflation in this country the
bigger implication I think is that the
bank of England will almost certainly
raise interest rates again again next
month the monetary policy committee
meets on the 7th of February on top of
the very strong wages growth figures
yesterday nominal wages growth that we
saw yesterday I think this will probably
uh tip the balance in favor of another
rate rise the market is assuming we'll
get another half point which will take
bank rate from three and a half percent
to four percent k